I was doing this kind of work affect you
emotionally
absolutely so the game it pays mentally
and it pays financially but it takes for
me mentally what is the price you pay
um you get depressed very very depressed
um you feel like you know sometimes you
can feel like it's not consensual even
though it is you kind of agree to it but
it just feels like off robotic
it makes you like not care for sex like
that even like if you're doing it for
pleasure right have you been alive
before I have how's this lifestyle
affect that affect that
it's crazy I've had people still fall in
love with me
in the game but um
it's not you could say it's not like
it's probably not real love because
um you probably I probably heard them if
I'm going out and you know sleeping with
other people